che bello ottobre bellissimo bellissimo
mese
questo è un ragazzo me lo infilo nella
tutti ragazzi e tutela tutti i ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video io sono
famigerati parlando col naso l'influenza
la cosa che odio di più nella vita
quando non vai a scuola non serva un
cazzo perché stai male basta
grazie il sistema immunitario per avere
così poca skill questo nuovamente qui su
aids cul0 manco legge minchia dato
stupido l'influenza mia annebbia il
cervello siamo sul raid school 101 se
sta scritta degli spasmi non fate
domande perché non so perché si porti
devi dare una calmata zia ma serio
è questo il concetto di epico secondo il
creatore di questo gioco facciamo un
menù alternativo ha detto il creatore di
questo gioco facciamo una scritta con
degli spasmi maledizione ragazzi
incominciavo perché vi spiego che cosa
sa di cosa si tratta sta roba
exan day today c'è una banana che bella
grafica di passare gli esami con ogni
mezzo necessario
ok cerca le risposte mica sul telefono
curie sul banco manco fossi e
condividili sì perché io do suggerimenti
miei compagni usa degli strumenti per la
distruzione prova non essere scoperto
buona fortuna
quindi ragazzi oggi fari jv insegna come
copiare a scuola vi do istruttivi e
genitori che sta lavorando questo vino
non fatevi problemi perché tanto non è
un video serio forza ai ragazzi non ho
ben capito chi sa io sono questo con la
freccia va bene quindi mi chiamo john
non so un cazzo come al solito quindi
vediamo mi piace anzi col timer vicino
alla lavagna bruttissimo allora prima
vedere se riusciamo alza la mano
professore non ho capito come mi chiamo
cerca cerca sul telefono circa sul
telefono
hai capito alzano la mano ti scoprono
perfetto bravo ok giusto giusto grazie
wikipedia ok alza la mano ma io devo far
rispondere giusto tutti quanti o solo me
stesso a bruce suggerire a quello di
fianco ai suggerisci tra tronisti al
tipo cioè dei capelli inguardabili un
insegnante bene ho suggerito la
suggerisce ancora se sia quello dietro
ci ha mica ragazzi sto professore un
mongoloide come fanno un accordo sono un
deficiente
va bene aeroplano di carta su di lui
cazzo ma non ho fatto in tempo a velo
passato nord est ama quindi bassa
oddio la e bocciato solo lui ce l'ha
fatta va bene quattro su cinque hanno
passato ha quindi io devo nuova ma
geniale quindi il mio compito è quello
di far passare tutti quanti quindi non
devo rispondere a più domande ne basta
una perfetta di niente a posto ho capito
ok quindi lui cerca sul telefono e poi
una volta che ha risposto giusto deve
suggerire a tutti gli altri è il
professore non se ne deve accorgere va
bene
alza la mano cerca su internet anche il
prefetto questo qua si alza la mano
secondo me si stupra il professore non
lo so perchè alza la mano zio bravo
suggerisce coli fianco perfetto quindi
io adesso concluso qui flip va bene
tasso pini ci sono alcune persone che
possono lanciare completamente il banco
senza un motivo
alza la nostra mano testa di culo atto
questi cori striscioni non fanno un
cazzo lo so io no mi ha scoperto
[ __ ] ale
vabbè dai uno è fallito prima fare tipo
così soria inganno banco e nei tra i
dubbi stanco caso banana cosa hai detto
zio capanna ma non ho capito
adesso ho capito che niente ho finito il
tema e okaka anzi a suo tempo però
quanti hanno perso quanti hanno vinto i
due si sono salvati tra cui uno che ha
lanciato il banco che tra l'altro è
seduto sul niente
va bene 2 su 11 sempre meglio della mia
classe delle superiori ragazzi molto
meglio come che c'è tutta questa
solidarietà in classe non suggerivo
cazzo di nessuno mi facevo solo
suggerire quella flippato il banco tu
suggerisci no tu philippe al banco
perché ti sei incazzato la nota hanno
suggerito per che picchiano gente a caso
è morto un prof
cosa è successo e cosa è successo
bellissimo e morto un prof a caso non ha
un [ __ ] stesso sto gioco bellissimo
interroga se andiamo avanti c tanto
funziona sta cosa vedo
papa parlava ma che cazzo cosa stanno
facendo
non lo sapeva bene così diciamo sera
ecco anche lui piaceva al telefono ho
visto c'è un sacco di tempo visto che
c'è solo un prof ragazzi vai vai vai vai
veloce cielo c'e non c'e succedute qui
c'è il paper plane meraviglioso leroy
quella rimasto fermo è un idiota si è
pagato tutto ragazzi forza no suggerita
quello che sapeva sono in corone quello
cosa sta facendo sotto il banco santo di
dio è stata alquanto strano perché la
fila di destra tutta fail siano ragazzi
stavolta ce la posso fare search papa
banana tua sorella poi cercare su
internet questo qui ok ha quindi ognuno
al suo ruolo quelli che hanno la
spazzola in testa profili pane i banchi
quelli ciccioni alzano la mano e quelli
nerd cercano su internet
avevo capito e io che ho le cuffie tiro
gli aeroplanini fantastico devi
suggerire zio suggerisci su gen si
suggerisce
non sarà accorge perfetto non se n'è
accorto che suggerisce progetto sul
rientro passaparola ragazzi gioco di
squadra gioco di squadra bravissimi
questa la classe che voglio da grandi
farete grandi cose lui con l'areoplanino
come fa suggerire se non c'è nessuno
vicino mi spiegate ma perché l'avete
messo lì cono con l'aeroplanino meglio
di prima ragazzi dai 4 che non è male
cioè pensavo molto peggio 4 su 11
quanti minchia siamo inglesi questi
quella freccia è uscito è un [ __ ]
questa volta liberi tutti devono vincere
2 p non se ne accorge perché un
deficiente non si sa come cedric pro di
harry potter ma non è morto michael
plain lui altissimo mica che tiro da
maestro mi carica è difficile non
sembrava veramente difficile l'unica
roba ragazzi che non ho capito e come
suggerire a questo qua che davanti vabbè
ci sarà stato un modo ma non l'ho
trovato aver pazienza regalo dovrei aver
fatto tutto finito il tempo prima che me
lo bastona se finito prima che lo
bastona ma no ma la rosa bruciato 8 su
11 6 ragazzi per un po più di stile nel
vestirsi magari perche c'e un tizio con
lacustri c'è un prof ragazzi con la crus
rift potrebbe essere un po più
complicato del previsto
search cioè non riesco quando un solo
pro figura season 2 ricercato su inter
non potete avere tutti il telefono
michela più semplice whisper a lui così
può flippare il banco fate una domanda
fatta una domanda rise and awe che
allora terzo può suggerire a victor che
però mica pieno di prof che palle
rise and papasso shiatsu ma [ __ ]
non la voglio fare io sta verifica donna
voglio fare anch'io professori di merda
anno lui alza la mano papa parlava mi
spiegate perchè 1 livello che lo script
ragazzi non lo capisce quanto altro
bellissimo perché se quello che ha
finito la verifica flip al banco non gli
dicono niente va bene quindi ragazzi se
voi in classe finite le verifiche le
fate giuste poteva di sviluppare il
bancomat e sega già un professore
difficile ci mancherebbe che su due ex
ben 1 prendete in tre sono riusciti è
bassa ma forse neanche in uno solo ma
com è solo uno solo quello che ha
guardato sullo smartphone fantastico ama
più franchi così storia eccomi ragazzi
sono io sono io sono esageratamente io
questo che c'è al telefono anche per
presenti 8 geri si alza la mano alza la
mano altra mano ok suggerisce a quello
di franco coppi perfetto jacket
imbragati ok ok non se n'è reso conto
york ladra che vabbè non importa la
ragazzi ci ho provato un gara ghazi
qualcuno di tanto in tanto potrebbe
anche studiare a tempo perso perché non
sapevo un cazzo di niente appunto ci si
può fare perché non ragazzi in questo
minchia che tiro da maestro non se n'è
assolutamente accorto il tizio un
[ __ ] genio suggerisci suggerisci
suggerisci perfetto c'è un fatto ci
credo allora che amica richiami che
stava e sta diventando tragica sito
acqua effetto questo qualche file alzata
la marazza la mano a salvare un cazzo va
bene non l'ho saputo bene dovrei ha nei
fatti almeno sette fantastico ci siamo
ragazzi questa è quella giusta me lo
sento
me lo sento proprio della vita pokémon
questo si chiama pokémon suggerisce a
pokemon che se lo merita bene perfetto
che social paperplane quindi io con lui
suggerisco con chi posso suggerire exor
paperplane porca eva calcio in otto
attenzione a nyon
credo di aver capito ragazzi credo di
aver capito che se filippo il banco
davanti a un prof
quello a si paga in serie a ha detto no
non come ha fatto per me
come non è possibile perché s'è fermato
all'angolo vai vai a zio paperplane che
tempestività fantastico il prof ragazzi
si è bloccato dietro quindi no problem
ho capito ragazzi come bagarre e sto
gioco non lo so perché funziona
benissimo chi è che non è non è riuscito
meraviglioso va bene va bene ne ho fatti
almeno sette ragazzi è record sono
andate tutela schifo ultimamente 9 mi
chiamo funzione palais ragazzi va bene
così no problem sono baciati di nuovo
ragazzi uno da una parte né dall'altra
che culo o provateci a scuola se durante
una verifica nuovo buttate a terra al
banco vedete se i professori si pagano
se si basano sul serio fa vigeva
insegnato il trucco della vita che c'è
tutto il tempo per suggerire qualche
roba che lui lui lui lui lui lui
perfetto lui esperti o lento o lento o
veloce basta che suggerisce con nessun
altro può lanciare e cose porca eva si
grande paperplane by velocissimo o rega
questo crea è andata benissimo questa
l'ho fatto così con tutti tranne sto
povero cristo che si è sacrificato ma
non verrà dimenticato fratello
meraviglioso
meraviglioso 10 su 11 non so quando
ricapita a 11 su 13 islamiche a sbaglio
sempre con te questo la dice lunga su
come ero bravo io nelle verifiche di
matematica provando a rifare il primo
ragazzi solo per curiosità per vedere se
funziona se riesco a fare recentemente
chiaro quanto era semplice cazzo dopo
aver fatto tutti questi incasinati mi
sembra una cagata a fare il primo alza
la mano tesa di culo
vai così file perfetto paperplane
[Musica]
pacchia ragazzi in tempo record ancora
un minuto 2 mancavano sono riuscito a
completare una classe non ci sto
credendoci questo 5 avere cassiere che
posso concludere qui l'episodio mi sa di
avermi fatto capire bene come si copia
in classe è alquanto figo sto gioca
soprattutto alquanto istruttivo non
potevo scoprirlo prima ai ragazzi spero
che vi sia piaciuto a cavallo del 2000
piaciuto un commento è un mi piace vi
chiedo scusa ragazze c'avevo la voce un
po strano e l'influenza c'è influenza
iso rial esauriti discrete micidiale un
prossimo video e ragazzi